me club is from Phil Phil looks just
like but he still look like you guys he
fell yeah I consumed who do y'all think
that he looks like who's he one of the
quartet dudes oh he does a little bit
huh
but he also looks a little bit like who
is it oh I know you talking about you do
yeah that's singer right who is it
that's here Luke Louis Capaldi yeah
Capaldi that's what I'm thinking yeah he
looks a little bit like glucose Cavalli
I don't even think that that is Luis
Capaldi is like probably one of the
hottest Scottish or Irish singers there
always is a young man he sounds Italian
it's Lewa did you see mix history is all
[Laughter]
oh he does look a little bit like that
and Tim doin he's a good dude I see that
Tim doing mm-hmm that's who it is looks
like kind of slim Dylan I feel like yeah
but looks like Luis Capaldi a little if
Lewis kind of joined like it got any
more like a boy band yeah and didn't
have as much swagger kinda maybe here we
go yeah he looks yeah he looks yeah he
looks like Louis Capaldi's like other
brother the brother that did science or
gang what's up Brendan what's up Theo
listen you know do my part
social distancing but no sports to watch
run or not a podcast waiting for some
new episodes and I just found myself
googling and googling and stumbled
across the little king of the sting and
I'd love to get you guys his opinion on
the sniper come what you think about
this now I don't know if Steve Kerr was
off that sauce or what when when came
time to name this last child here but um
and what do y'all think about Steve Kerr
naming his kid this is Japanese whiskey
no the best bet might be to have
Chappelle read this name haha but in
case Brennan or dices
trying to say it too fast fellas and
Brendan just pretend like you're
ordering some some more Japanese
Wow Steve Kerr named his kid Nick Kerr
you had to say it huh it's Nick but you
had to say it yeah huh I don't you would
know no I wouldn't
called text David dude I don't know
about this what do you I mean I have no
I don't even know who to ask in the room
of the players like they're like oh
what's the baby's days like Nick well
that's cool he's like my last names car
I better be Mick cop what do you guys
think on let's go to the culture corner
is this what do you do - you shut the
kid down do you change his name or
Nicholas Kurt Nicholas Carr yeah how old
is he he probably struggled in school
I'll tell you that much yeah I hope you
didn't go to all-black school hates your
belly dad Steve curry and I go on
all-black school he's around a bunch of
black he was taking em put the base
round by asian it's you know yeah but
even if it was like it was like a
private school or something I'm sure he
ran into some some people had some
questions about it
questioned a few times getting
interesting at Steve Kerr named his son
Nick oh it's a neck-and-neck ooh
people are kind of like yeah maybe it
was this grandpa's name look I think
someone's it's a way to change the tide
you know this is Nick Kerr
man know what the problem is it just
feels so natural to you when you say it
with me it's a little bit of a stroke
with you it just glides out yeah Brenda
you say it more you don't say it all the
time dude and you've been saying it
probably around the house to your
children yeah dude look at these little
knickers I know yeah Brendon get it
together dude look at him Oh looky you
just be frowning right now smooth like
this glitter dude get that glare in your
eye when you say just roll wow you've
changed man Steve Kerr's changed I guess
great [ __ ] question though are you
just trying to get back in the league
you know it's crazy man well this little
twink himself what about this now
there's a lot of probably armed
a lot of Asian names that have that have
some different type of connotation to
them don't they like it they're like a
lot of is their last name ni k ka like
the whiskey not to my understanding or
my knowledge no brain is just trying to
find a way to say it akid
who break into your house and steal a
recipe potatoes are growing like all the
money but he took our [ __ ]
salt-and-pepper field looks like the
yin-yang orphan
it's heady yeah yeah man it's out there
it's good I'm stuck on slope ashy look
like you're a boy oh my gosh regular
coke all the same lemme go you got it
tighten up you got a tighten up
so King understand it then let's go to
the rest of the group here what do you
guys think on Steve Kerr's son's name
Nick Kerr I'll sting it there's so many
names coming from this is coming from a
real Nick over here Jen what do you
think I I feel like he just didn't think
about saying the two words together and
he really likes the name Nick but I was
stinger to I would think about it more
in sting it nobody goes by Nicholas has
to Nicky Nick Nicholas for sure Nicky
yeah must be friends I like your
attitude cat
draymond Green might have a problem
David West I think whatever problem
David Western here's like the most
racist player in the were like oh like a
racist guy really you wouldn't yeah I
mean nobody's really gonna get into
supporting the name I don't think maybe
a couple people I don't think anybody
gives a [ __ ]
yeah I think you couldn't have both
names on the back of the jersey probably
from like we had a guy growing up we
didn't have him but he was around
and he wrote the end where he had he
made these hats right on the front it
said the n-word across the front but on
the back it said just joking across the
back so it was like and I bet they sold
in - hazel - yeah that's it he only made
two you sold out minutes but it's not a
good habit do you still have that Steve
Kerr son I've never had it but yes and
got made a couple hats anyway yeah
danger sting it I don't feel comfortable
kinging anything yeah I do not either
yeah all we want and Brendon obviously
Brennan voted with with his behavior
what else you got what else you got
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]